This is the beamer, a good PEMF unit, so the beamer is a low Gauss PEMF, so PEMF units are measured
in the Gauss output of electricity. There's low Gauss output PEMFs on the market,
two that are popular is the IMRS and the beamer brands. Are they good units?
You know, if you have them, use them. Unfortunately, you know, all the research on PEMF,
there's a plethora of research for PEMF and how PEMF, which is pulse-electromagnetic field therapy,
it's electrical pulse. PEMF therapy can be extremely beneficial to improve cell membrane potential,
increase the cell charge, increase person's health in so many ways. It can be very beneficial.
It can decrease inflammation to talk about, you know, things that will help osteoarthritis,
or degenerative arthritis, or even inflammatory arthritis. PEMF is great for that.
However, all the research on PEMF was done with high Gauss PEMF units. Let me give you an example.
So the beamer and the IMRS function under a thousand Gauss. I think they're like 700 Gauss.
Professional PEMF is between 25 and 30,000 Gauss. That's a big difference. 25,000 Gauss versus 700 Gauss.
That's a big difference. So you can't really, I know those companies steal that data in a sense and say,
see, we're a PEMF machine and look at all this wonderful data, how it does all this wonderful stuff.
Well, it's not really a real fair comparison because that was tested with 25 to 30,000 Gauss
machine, all those studies, not a machine that puts out 700 Gauss. Now, not say that these low Gauss PEMFs
don't have benefit. I think they all have benefit. I just don't know that they have the same benefit
of a good quality PEMF. The problem is that their good quality PEMF machine is super expensive.
Like, you know, we have a PEMF in our office. It's 30,000 Gauss PEMF, but they're also $38,000.
Well, who's going to buy that for their house? Nobody. But you can buy a good, you know, or a
BEMF might cost you $7, 8, 9,000. For $9,000, you can buy a 7,000 Gauss PEMF, which a lot of clinics
have. You might go to a car project or a physical therapist that uses a PEMF and it's a 7,000 Gauss PEMF.
It's much better quality PEMF than a 700 Gauss PEMF. So is it a good PEMF unit?
Yeah, if you haven't used it, it's better than nothing. Would I spend $7,000, $5,000, $3,000 on one of those?
No, no, I wouldn't. If I was going to spend, you know, if I had a limited budget,
if I could afford a $9,000, $7,000 Gauss PEMF, I would choose that. Or I'd save up to get that,
honestly. So yeah, I don't want to knock a company. I just think they oversell and they're not
really using correct data. I don't like that when companies, it's not incorrect, but it's not
really data that's based upon the Gauss output of your machine. So it's like a laser company,
there's different levels of laser, class 1, 2, 3, 4 of laser. Well, all the research on laser
is done with a class 4 laser, then a company that's selling a class 2 laser is pilfery that data and
say, look at what laser does. Well, yeah, you're still a laser company. You still sell a laser, but,
you know, it's not going to do the exact same thing as a class 4 laser. It's just not really fair.
But it's still a class 2 laser is better than no laser, I guess. So